welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of Ahsoka
episode 6 far far away a title that
evokes the classic Star Wars blue text
that was invoked by Jason sindula last
episode the phrase Far Far Away proving
to be the answer to the question of
where thrawn went as well as the answer
to this question
so many cool questions and deeper bits
of historical lore tied into this
episode so let's take it scene by scene
for all the details you might have
missed and thanks to missed play for
sponsoring this video more about them in
a moment and again we really really
appreciate you tuning in to these Star
Wars analyzes it's honestly an honor to
stay up late riding these breakdowns
every week I just care a lot about this
series and I want to share all of that
with you so let's dive in okay over that
lucasfilm opening we hear this
according to the closed captioning
distant Pergo calls but we don't begin
this episode distant from the Pergo we
open with them inside of one so this
call being distant tells us that we are
actually hearing this call from the
perception of the three great mothers of
paridia native death Miri night sisters
who harnessed these pergol this call is
how they know the Jedi is coming
hyperspace in this opening shot looks
different than we've ever seen it before
in Star Wars normally it's a glowing
blue tunnel surrounding the traveler now
it's streaks of teal and pink and yellow
and orange all the colors in the visible
spectrum streaking past the whales
streaking between each other and under
their fins it's just such a cool way of
showing that this form of hyperspace
travel is beyond the kind that we've
seen before because we are traveling
from Galaxy to Galaxy now you may
remember that moment in the Mandalorian
chapter 17 when grogu and din jarin were
traveling through hyperspace and grogu
saw a burgle and I might be crazy but in
this shot for a few frames on the right
side of screen you do see a blur through
hyperspace on the other side of this
that could could be dens in one
Starfighter I had to scrub through it
all free by frame to see this I think I
honestly spent an hour staring at the
shot but now I can't like unsee it now
maybe I asking would the timeline match
up Ahsoka Tano doesn't appear in the
Mandalorian season 3 but Captain Carson
Tina does appear on both seasons and I
suppose it's possible for his mission
with Hera on ctOS happens before all
that stuff he got into with the
Mandalorian and like Tim Meadows in the
Mandalorian season three but you know
for all we know the pro girl could be
bending time with their form of
hyperspace travel I just want this to be
true let me have it Ahsoka tells huyang
that she remembers the Pergo from the
stories that he would tell them when we
were younglings back at the temple oh
yeah
history of the Galaxy baths one two and
three
one being the best of course I love this
it could be a meta nod to the Star Wars
original trilogy where I would
definitely say the first is the best but
you know I can respect the opinion that
The Empire Strikes Back might be better
although we could also see Parts one two
and three as the three trilogies the
prequels the original trilogy in the
sequel Trilogy and Ahsoka might be
saying that the prequels are the best
because that would be more of her era
but really she spans all the eras look
if you legit think that the prequels are
better than the original trilogy no
shame I just think Ahsoka would be more
into a Trilogy that ends with Anakin
being redeemed rather than one that ends
in tragedy for him even if Dave filoni
identifies most with the prequel era but
that's just our meta understanding of
this what does this mean for the
characters in the universe George Lucas
originally conceived his Star Wars
narrative as the Journal of the wills
with the Skywalker Saga being an epic
myth told by an advanced alien race
called The Wills to inspire their youth
which is why every film would begin with
the phrase a long time ago in a galaxy
far far away which again supplies this
episode with its title and is a phrase
now being examined by this Ahsoka series
as we for the first time travel from one
Galaxy within the Star Wars Universe to
another but what would the actual in
universe history of the Galaxy be that
huyang would tell all these young Jedi
currently the accepted chronology begins
with something called the Wellspring of
Life the birthplace of midichlorians
this gets explored in Clone Wars season
6 episodes 11 and 12 episode 11 takes
Yoda to Dagobah where he hears qui-gon's
voice explaining to him that all living
things form the living force and that
feeds the more abstract Cosmic force and
that Cosmic force is contained in this
Wellspring so in episode 12 Destiny Yoda
heads to that Wellspring and encounters
inside of it this kind of planet
geysering up all this metichlorian
energy and he encounters these five
masked priestesses who each represent
emotions and put Yoda through various
trials it's a really cool Arc and it's
really where life began in this galaxy
sometime after this the gods of mortis
came to live in the Ethereal realm of
mortis and then eons after that sometime
around 25 000 BBY the Dai Bindu an order
of priests who were precursors to the
Jedi established what became the Jedi
Order on ochto led by the prime Jedi
which was the figure depicted in that
Mosaic pool that Luke step aside in The
Last Jedi and I feel like that last part
of it the dibendu would be the part one
that huyang would have told Ahsoka about
the dawn of the Jedi Order as the
Wellspring of life and mortis were kind
of surprises to Yoda and Ahsoka and
Obi-Wan and Anakin like while these
mythological elements might have been
buried somewhere in the Jedi archives I
don't think it's something that huyang
would have been programmed with and told
us bedtime stories to all these young
Jedi on The Crucible then again in
Rebels season 4 Palpatine and his like
archaeologist's friend did kind of
mention how the Jedi archives mentioned
the gods of mortis I just don't know how
much all the Jedi younglings would know
about still they are important for us to
know and I will explain why later anyway
Ahsoka worries that Sabine went with
Balin willingly and that she didn't have
enough time to train Sabine how to make
the right choice but huyang says the
force provides Insight but doesn't give
all the answers the house the Sabine it
was the omnichoice
Choice she made for herself
that is your fear ah fear he's implying
that fear is about the dark side you
know at least anger hate suffering he's
saying don't let fear corrupt your mind
Ahsoka so Ahsoka takes the note and she
forces appear out of her mind getting
back to some stories and second thought
tell me one of those stories
a long time ago
in a galaxy far far away and I love it
because that is what Star Wars is for us
a way for us to escape our anxieties and
just lose ourselves and some great
stories and this is actually the first
time we hear this spoken aloud in Star
Wars but unlike the wills and some other
Galaxy telling the story of Star Wars
who Yang must be talking about beans
from another galaxy from his perspective
who came to this Galaxy and settled it
those could be the celestial deities
like the mortise Gods but this episode
also implies other races like the death
of Miri originate from other galaxies
let's move on when the eye of Scion
exits hyperspace it leaves a trail that
crackles with electric bolts which feels
like a sippy violation of nature like
they weren't meant to go on this journey
like notice also that ring was
smoldering orange when it first arrives
and then cools down like it really feels
like they pushed it to the limit so they
approached the planet to paridia
surrounded by a ring which turns out
it's composed of pergol Bones the Sita
star map depicted paridius surrounded by
a ring of pergol but I didn't know that
meant a ring of Dead pergol Morgan says
paridia is they ancient Homeworld and my
ancestors the death of Mary so the death
of Mary the people of the planet
dathomir home to Maul's mother mother
talzin were not originally native to
that planet dathomir they settled that
planet after migrating from another
galaxy and they just named it after
their own race this is a huge deal
Morgan says of the pergol my people were
among the first to harness and ride the
creatures in the days before time was
counted geez between the pergol and
Danny Trejo telling us the witches that
mayor also used to ride the rancorps
these witches were just writing
everything now in Star Wars Legends the
ancient ricotta were the first to use
hyperspace technology and based on that
blue kyber crystal celebrating the
Rakuten Uprising mentioned in the Andor
episode War the rakutans are Star Wars
Canon but Morgan says that the death of
Miri were among the verse so there could
have been like a few of them but she
says the days before time was counted
which would be old pre-dating recorded
history pre-dating the Jedi Order
because when the Jedi started they were
counting years back then Balin says
Meridia
there's a graveyard ah so it wasn't a
fairy tale that a group hearing it was
more of a ghost story a track that Pergo
make at the end of their lives kind of
like elephants migrating back to their
known burial sites that's a real thing
folks that elephant graveyard in The
Lion King was based on a real ritual
that these massive mammals do sounds
like purple do a similar thing their
drop ship takes them past towering
statues of nice sister heads atop
towering pillars with their mouths
contorted in this grotesque scream I
wonder if these could function as
amplifiers for the great Mother's voices
that Echo back to Morgan through time
and space the statues on Arcana remember
were full statues that had bodies and
feet but just their heads severed this
is kind of the opposite it's just heads
unscanny skinny pillars it's kind of
creepy like they're giant pest
dispensers but it looks so cool remember
the statues inside the ruins on Arcana
were not screaming like this they looked
at peace so I just gotta like the idea
that it's the witches who stayed who
cried and it's the witches who left who
listen they approached this towering
structure built into the side of the
cliff that looks a lot like a dower
Minas tirith from returning the king a
top the statue is a more pristine
version of the citas ruins the slabs
uncorrected by the elements and Morgan
finds here three Knight sisters the
great mothers according to the episode
credits their names are laquisis played
by Jane Edwina Seymour who played the
board Queen in Star Trek Picard she's on
the right with a rounded headdress
flotho played by Claudia Black from
Stargate sg1 and played Chloe Frazier
from the Uncharted games she's in the
center with a single pointed headdress
who does most of the talking and then
actual paw played by Gerald Prescott
Galleon known for playing Madame Xanadu
on the Swamp Thing show she's on the
left with a two-pointed headdress so
these names are a fascinating choice
because lechesis clotho and atropos are
the names of the three fates of Greek
mythology that we've referenced before
those Fates were also known as the morai
which is where Dave filoni got the name
of ahsoka's bird companion that
represents a daughter of mortis now
these witches of course were similar red
headdresses that mother tellsin wore and
that appearance was based off of
original designs for the Sith created
for The Phantom Menace and then
repurposed for Clone Wars but the fact
that these three addresses that we see
here are all slightly different could be
telling us something because in Greek
mythology clotho is the youngest and she
spins the threat of human life laquesis
is the middle who measures the thread
and then atropos is the oldest who cuts
that thread and decides when people die
so this cloth though with a K has the
headdress with one point like the
pointed needle that spins the thread
laquisis has a rounded headdress but
aktrappa who would cut the threat of
Life as a two-pointed headdress like
scissors but of course these were the
three witches that Sabine referred to
when she figured out how to unlock this
spear in episode 1 but since those ruins
were thousands of years old I'm
wondering if there must always be three
caretaker witches on paridia it's kind
of like something that gets passed on
generation after generation but yes
these were the voices that Morgan
ellsmith Heard calling to her on citos
episode 2 was titled Toil and Trouble
which was an allusion to the three
witches of Macbeth Double Double Toil
and treble fire burning cauldron Babble
like the fates of Greek mythology they
tell the future they tell the future to
Macbeth but it's always cryptic and he's
having a political leader tries to use
his magic it always blows up in their
face clotho says welcome child of Darth
Amir
you do our ancestors credit
additional voice is layered on top of
her own kind of like mother Towson off
it did it's like when one of them talks
all three of them are talking they speak
for all the witches of dathomir
throughout time actropause says it reeks
of Jedi
and the kisses confirms it is dangerous
and this angle is especially creepy
because it's from sabine's point of view
as Jane Edwina Seymour looks directly
into the lens of the camera but they
refer to Sabine as it disrespecting Jedi
as animals like false practitioners of
the force because yeah it sounds like
they predate the Jedi Order but it also
indicates that Sabine does have some
connection to the force or at least a
connection to Ahsoka but my question is
do they smell this Jedi doo doo on Balin
because later they seem surprised when
Baylen is revealed as a former Jedi by
thrawn so Balin just must be really good
at blocking away that light side of the
force like the three witches in the
Arcana ruins they hover the Spheres of
their own palms and yeesh those
fingernails it's just an interesting
point to compare to Sabine because we
saw sabine's fingernails in episode 2
that her fingernail polish was chipped
and I like how the red beams that form
between these spheres kind of work like
rope that ties someone up it's a kind of
mystical thread being the weapon of
these three witches that are based on
the face and they're controlling the
threads of Fate three creatures howl at
the prettier Tower Dave filoni's wolf
Obsession coming back but rather than
wolves or loath wolves or anything these
are the howlers that we see later which
share their name with reptilian
creatures from Jedi Knight Jedi Academy
but these seem to be more canine and
horse-like the VFX on these things are
actually pretty good you kind of forget
that they're not actually there
bayland's dialogue in this episode is
fascinating this is a land of dreams and
Madness
children's stories come to life he
describes pretty as a kind of archetypal
Forest kind of like in A Midsummer
Night's Dream where magic can happen but
remember he called this place a
graveyard so it's a place where magic
once lived but when it was abandoned the
magic started to fade away kind of like
the ruins of valyria and A Song of Ice
and Fire the Doom of valyria led to the
gradual death of the dragons and Magic
leaving this world altogether but Shin
hati says that she didn't grow up with
these stories but Balon says stories of
this galaxy are considered folk tales
it's an ancient past
long forgotten with good reason
sometimes stories are just stories yeah
it's kind of a bit of commentary on how
sacred we should hold these Star Wars
stories I love stories about stories but
with Shin's response it kind of feels
like to the younger Star Wars fan what
was sacred to the older generation might
not be as sacred to them balen says that
he watched the Jedi Temple burn and he
couldn't make sense of it at the time
but as you get older look at history you
realize it's all inevitable full of the
Jedi rise of the empire it repeats again
and again
again now George Lucas would describe
this as oh it's like poetry it Rhymes
but for balance someone living inside of
this story he's just sick of the cycle
so when Shin asks them if thrawn will
give them power Balon says that sort of
power is fleeting what I seek is the
beginning so I may finally bring this
cycle to an end so balen is on a
fascinating Quest kind of like what
Daenerys Targaryen spoke of in season
five wanting to break the wheel before
she just kind of forgot about all that
in season seven and eight he wants a
deeper power on pretty a beyond thrawn
the beginning is here if the old stories
are true I have some thoughts on what
this could be later all of us have a
mobile game or two we can't put down but
thanks to missed place you can earn gift
cards while you play missed play is a
loyalty app for mobile Gamers they have
a vast library of games covering every
genre you could think of from casual
games to in-depth RPGs puzzle games and
more the more you play your favorite
game the more points you earn to redeem
your gift cards at your favorite stores
this includes Amazon Walmart Xbox
PlayStation and a ton of other places
including Visa which you know is is kind
of all stores if you are a mobile gamer
misplays a no-brainer you could be
earning points right now to get started
click the link in the video description
and make sure to use code rockstars30
inside the app to get 33 points which
will help toward redeeming your first
gift card code expires October 31st and
is limited to the first twenty thousand
so do not wait so inner dungeons being
Whispers
now in episode 5 when Ahsoka was pulled
out of that water she said Anakin but we
heard a female voice whisper from the
cosmos
be my voice might have been Sabine In
This Moment Sabine tries to use the
force to escape the dungeon and for a
second it seems like it's working but
now the rumbling is actually from the
Chimera the Star Destroyer of grand
Admiral thrawn that we saw in Rebels the
great mothers and Morgan watch it arrive
and I love how clotho seems to be
holding a rope or some prayer beads as
she would be the Fate to initially spins
that threat of life but the Chimera is
framed perfectly so that it looks like
it's rising from that Tower kept Alive
by night sister sorcery you can see one
of its top spherical Shield generators
and several plates all over its Hull are
augmented with gold Parts like the
material that I have Scion and Morgan's
Dropship are made out of these golden
editions may be repairs after the Pergo
wrapped their tentacles around this ship
or to make it so that the Chimera can
easily attach to the eye of Scion and
get that hyperspace toe you'll notice
that its underbelly has the same painted
pattern that it had in Rebels and I just
cannot get over the symmetry of the shot
perfectly bisected by the fold of the
hull and the corner of the town our
looks so good it's worth remembering
that since the Chimera got zipped off to
hyperspace by the pergol in the rebels
finale it still has on board presumably
the pieces of the lothal Jedi Temple
that Palpatine tried to use to corrupt
Ezra thrawn's forces are revealed
foreign
[Music]
ER has ever composed thus far the organ
plus the Electric Distortion just hit so
hard it's such an uncommon sound in Star
Wars and it's done to shock us with this
unlikely return of a face that you do
not normally see in Star Wars throw on
Stormtroopers chant his name
they still worship this guy despite
their dwindling numbers and their broken
armor yeah their armor looks awesome
it's been nine years since their Exile
in the rebels finale their Armor's dirty
it's got mismatched Parts probably taken
from some of the dwindling numbers used
to replace the broken pieces on the
people who are still surviving and it is
all cracked it's held together with red
cloth which shows how their wounds have
been nursed by these witches of the red
cloth and their Imperial Conformity has
been fused with a uniquely death Marian
aesthetic we actually saw some red cloth
wrapped around Maul's Temple behind that
bonfire and death Amir and the rebel
season 3 episode visions and voices now
the captain of these Stormtroopers is
Enoch played by West Chatham from the
expanse his Stormtrooper mask has been
fully broken and pieced back together
almost in the style of Japanese kintsuki
art but with a golden face mask kinda
like Tigris of Gaul and Gladiator a bit
like the golden mask of General clydesis
from Flash Gordon which was a huge
influence on George Lucas in the early
Star Wars films so it just shows how
Enoch is part of a post-imperial cult of
thrawn thrawn beats always loved art and
history actually the name Enoch comes
from the Bible who is a human who became
the immediate attendant to the throne of
God a human who actually got to enter
Heaven as a human this reflects Enoch
being at the side of this Godly figure
of thrawn now Lars Mickelson voice
thrawn and Rebels and plays him here in
images of this guy from trailers just do
not do him Justice because really it is
his voice that makes the character so
good he enters with one of the sickest
opening lines in live action of any Star
Wars character ever what was first just
a dream has become a frightening reality
for those who may oppose us holy
remember Bailey described paridia as a
land of dreams and Madness it's almost
like thrawn might have heard him with
that because his response here is what
was first a dream has become a
frightening reality Sorcerers deal in
dreams military strategists deal in
reality so a reminder thrawn is a chiss
with blue skin red eyes and I love how
they kept the v-shaped indentation on
his forehead we've talked before about
bronze Origins from Timothy zahn's 1991
novel heir to the Empire Dave baloney
bringing thrawn back in a cannon as the
villain of rebels season three and four
watch our Rebels recap series for more
info on this guy I also did a whole
thrawn timeline video back in April but
just seeing him here carrying himself
with Pomp and Majesty it is exactly true
to form for thrawn but that said notice
how they allowed Lars Mickelson to keep
his normal aged appearance in his build
if you look closely at his white uniform
it has been wrinkled and frayed in some
parts especially on the collar despite
thrawn's best efforts he cannot hide the
toll nine years has taken on him thrawn
is now the Napoleon million Bonaparte
Star Wars Napoleon being one of
History's Greatest military strategists
who took over France as a dictator and a
god king then exiled to Elba and then
made a grand return to power before his
final defeat at Battle of Waterloo Braun
is about to depart his Elba thrawn says
Enoch will begin the cargo transfer as
perthron's agreement with the great
mothers Morgan says I have seen the
catacombs
it will take some time so what is this
cargo they actually went into that in an
amazing episode of Wookie leaks that
came out last night go check it out but
actually later we see thrawn's Men
Moving these casket shaped containers
from the tower to the Chimera I think
these are corpses of past night sisters
and Knight Brothers on paridia that the
great mothers want to resurrect in this
other Galaxy kind of like what we saw
talson doing with the zombified corpses
and Clone Wars it's not just this small
army of Stormtroopers that thrawn plans
to return with he's going to come back
with a true Army of the Dead actually
later when we see one of these caskets
floating past the camera it shakes with
an unnatural Rattle
and as thrawn tells Morgan death and
Resurrection are common deceptions
played out by both nice sister and Jedi
a clue that these night sisters plot to
resurrect their dead actually morocc may
have been their first experiment at
doing just that so back in this scene
thrawn recognizes Balin then you must be
General balance girl
of the Jedi Order he calls him General
thrawn knows that Balin had a military
rank as a fighter in the Clone Wars this
shows his expertise he knows all the
names kind of like Batman knows all the
names of the detectives and the cops and
the gcpd so then thrawn meets Sabine
we're calling her as one of those Rebels
you chased down in Rebels season three
and four drawn is shocked that sabine's
obsession with finding Ezra was worth so
much to her oh that singular Focus would
reshape our galaxy
program of the fate of your Galaxy
and that belief you could see in his
eyes though some uncertainty over this
loose thread kind of like a chess master
trying to outsmart someone who is just
kind of winging it that's one of the
most frustrating people for Chess
Masters to play Sabine gets a howler and
blasters and Ezra's lightsaber back and
Enoch says die well
cold it is the kind of thing a
stormtrooper on this graveyard plane for
nine years just trying to make the most
of his death would say Sabine uses the
same kind of scanner that Han used to
look for Luke on Hoth and Empire Hera
actually used the bulkier version of it
last episode on cetas but Sabine gets
attacked by Marauders but whereas before
she's been a better shot with her
blasters and not as good with the
lightsaber now it's the opposite she has
to resort to the lightsaber and with the
lightsaber she successfully finishes
them off now as Balin Shin ride out from
the castle it does have some runes
written along the top this is not the
alphabet we figured out for our end
credit star map video it's a different
language it kind of looks like the Sith
language of erkatat but it's not that
either because this would predate that
these kind of look like the runes that
were on the inside of the Chalice that
Maul had Ezra drink from a daphomir when
he used the night sister magic to
combine their minds meanwhile thrawn and
Morgan observed this galaxy star map
which I'm gonna assume is not the Galaxy
peridia is in but the main galaxy star
map as it's all charted out whereas I
don't think the prettiest Galaxy would
be as charted so it looks like thrawn is
making plans for where to strike when
even turns we get some light-hearted
hijinx's episode of Sabine shaming the
howler and then meeting the notes which
are nomadic creatures akin to turtles or
crabs that disguise themselves as rocks
yeah they're a lot like the Ewoks but
there's more pragmatism they seem a bit
further along like they wear
multi-layered clothes with fasteners
made out of teeth my wife pointed this
out but those might not be shells that
are part of their Anatomy but rather
sell backpacks that they wear because
think about it how else would they get
these slim fitting clothes on their
bodies but this note recognizes the
rebel Insignia on sabine's pauldron
because he has a similar patch proving
that they know Ezra Bridger it makes
sense that Ezra would get along with
these guys as throughout Rebels he'd
love to disguise himself in different
uniforms and using Silla synonyms like
at some points he calls himself Jabba
the Hutt and Lando Calrissian Balon
finds a severed staff to knows the beans
lightsabers sever this and bailing tells
Shin about Ezra Bridger comes from a
breed of Balkan Jedi trained in the wild
after the temple fell bokeh in reversed
to the wooden training swords that we
saw Ahsoka and Sabine using in episode
three so this just kind of refers to a
homeschool Jedi but balen tells Shane
that she's not a Jedi maybe strain is a
Jedi
you I train to be something more now
Bayland says that he misses the idea of
the Jedi Order but not the true weakness
of the Jedi Order and he sees the future
here on this planet in what was once the
great witch Kingdom of the dothamiri and
he says while the great mothers are
fleeing balance sees an opportunity
perhaps they flee a power
greater than their own something calls
to me can't you hear it something stirs
here can't you see it so what is this
greater power in this paridian Wasteland
beyond thrawn that the great mothers are
fleeing but Balin is drawn to maybe the
mortise Gods which might explain balance
reluctance to kill Ahsoka because Ahsoka
has a spirit of the daughter inside of
her maybe balen is drawn to the purest
form of the forced religion through the
father before it was bastardized by the
cryptable Jedi Order but maybe this
great power is bendu the force being in
Rebel season 3 that eluded thrawn and
predicted thrawn's defeat at the arms of
the pergol remember bendu was kind of an
agnostic he reached out to both Kane and
Ezra and Maul and in the rebel season 3
finale he equally destroyed Imperial
forces and the rebel Fleet he's kind of
on neither side and would be really fun
for a thrawn to see bendu again but I'm
gonna throw another theory at you that
power that Balin recognizes could be the
priestesses from the Wellspring of Life
what if the Knight sisters branched out
from those priestesses and the
priestesses cast them out of the
Wellspring like Lucifer from heaven and
then banish them to this hell of pridia
the reason why the death of Mary might
have migrated to our galaxy could have
been some gradual attempt to get closer
and closer back into that Garden of Eden
I gotta dig into this in another video
because it's really heady and there's a
lot of moving Parts but Sabine follows
the notes to their Lakeside Village with
rounded trailers it kind of looks like
the shells that they wear looks like the
females of this group wear shawls over
their heads there's just a lot of good
World building with these things and
then our man Ezra Bridger returns I knew
I could count on you he appears out of
focus over sabine's left shoulder just
as Anakin appeared to Ahsoka in the
world Between Worlds Iman espani plays
Ezra Bridger nine years older and he has
a beard and he looks just like his
father Ephraim Bridger even with the
hand on the hip he has animated Ezra's
crystal blue eyes and that wrist Tech
that Ezra wore on his left arm
throughout the rebels series Sabine and
Ezra pick up right where they left off
with some playful banter that they
always had typical
always a plan
never a good one hey
it worked didn't it
didn't it and I love that sudden
seriousness from Ezra like think about
it for nine years Ezra would not have
known if lothal was saved or if the
rebels ever had a chance of defeating
Empire he just just kind of had to make
peace with being completely out of the
fight and being completely in the blind
but Ezra asks house being found him like
how she got there and she Ducks this
difficult conversation the same way
Ahsoka sidestepped huyang's difficult
questions in the opening scene once Ezra
finds out what's being sacrificed to get
here I don't think he's gonna be very
happy but the great Mother's warned
thrawn that another Jedi approaches and
he susses it out who it is could it be
the reasonably deceased of socatana he
tells Morgan that death and Resurrection
are common deceptions played out by both
night sister and Jedi and since Balin
was a former Jedi his words should be
treated as flawed Braun says I want to
know how background history home Wells
her master everything yes this is always
a huge part of thrawn's strategic
approach to learn everything about his
enemy their history their art and
weaponize it and it's interesting that
he doesn't know that ahsoka's Master was
Anakin Skywalker something that Baylen
skull knew but he was part of the Jedi
Order during the Clone Wars drawn wasn't
he was a military figure but there is
evidence from various books that thrawn
was one of the few people who deduced
that Anakin Skywalker and Darth Vader
were the same person so as soon as he
finds out that Anakin Skywalker was a
master he's gonna know that Darth Vader
was her master Brawn orders to destroy
any approaching star whales with
prejudice and he turns back to the great
mothers great mothers I should once
again require the aid of your dark magic
the thread of Destiny demands it Grand
Admiral so the closed captioning spells
this magic
m-a-g-i-c-k which gives it a more
Supernatural metaphysical quality like
magic with a K is what witches do but he
says once again so what past instance
did thrawn use the great Mother's magic
other than to summon morganelle's bit
like in a way that he could use it again
could it have been these mothers that
Drew Ahsoka into the world Between
Worlds to wrestle with ahsoka's demons
and that Ahsoka just successfully passed
that test did they actually use the
lothal Jedi Temple that is still on the
Chimera to do this look make no mistake
folks thrawn's respect for this magic is
transactional at best and the real story
here is the relationships that Ahsoka
and balance skull have to the fairy
tales that they were told as kids are
the stories true are they only fantasies
that happen in a galaxy far far away
thank you so so much for watching this
breakdown you can support our Channel by
grabbing an Ahsoka inspired fulcrum
shirt available at nerd riot.shop please
subscribe to the break room for all of
our episodes of WikiLeaks or Ahsoka
after show And subscribe to all three
channels of the new rockstars Network
thanks to Noah Chen for helping write
and research this breakdown you can
follow me at EA boss following the
rockstars thanks for watching and I'll
see you next time bye
foreign
[Music]